AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT
GAME, BAD JEOPARDY ANSWERS.
BAD JEOPARDY ANSWERS.
(JEOPARDY-LIKE THEME PLAYING)
NOW, WHEN WE'RE NOT...
>> SPEAKING OF COPYRIGHT...
>> HARDWICK: WELL, I MEAN, UH,
IT'S A CLOSE PROXIMITY.
IT'S A SIMILE.
>> IT'S GOT THE SAME KIND OF FUN
VIBE, YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, IT'S GOT THAT
SAME SORT OF, LIKE, "HEY, WE'RE
IN A KEYBOARD STORE.
LET'S SEE WHAT THIS SETTING
DOES."
THAT'S THE THEME.
ALL RIGHT.
WHEN WE'RE NOT TAKING THE
INTERNET DOWN A PEG, WE SURE
ENJOY SOME QUALITY TRIVIA
PROGRAMMING, AND ON TOP OF THAT,
OF COURSE, IS JEOPARDY, OUR
SISTER SHOW, UH, UNOFFICIALLY.
UNOFFICIALLY.
IT'S VERY SIMILAR.
>> CHRIS, YOU LOOK GREAT IN THAT
PHOTO.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I REALLY... I WAS 19 THERE.
>> OH.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
SO, UH, WE THOUGHT IT'D BE FUN
TO PLAY OUR VERSION OF IT RIGHT
HERE.
UH, COMEDIANS, I'M GONNA GIVE
YOU A CLUE.
I WANT YOU TO BUZZ IN WITH THE
APPROPRIATE ANSWER.
REMEMBER TO PHRASE IN THE FORM
OF A QUESTION, AND I WILL
REMEMBER TO HAVE A HUGE DICK
LIKE ALEX TREBEK.
THIS IS... BASICALLY, THIS IS A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO ALEX TREBEK.
HE TURNED 76 YEARS OLD RECENTLY,
SO HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
AND I'M GONNA START THE CLOCK
RIGHT NOW.
TAYLOR SWIFT.
SETH MORRIS.
>> WHO SPEAKS TO ME DIRECTLY
THROUGH HER SONGS?
I LOVE YOU, TAYLOR SWIFT!
I LOVE YOU.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS AND
RESTRAINING ORDER.
NEXT ONE, ENDANGERED SPECIES.
MO... OBERG.
>> WHAT IS THE NUMBER ONE THING
ON MY LIST OF COOL THINGS TO
SHOOT WITH A CROSSBOW?
>> HARDWICK: P... OH, (BLEEP).
OH. THAT SON OF A BITCH!
BUT POINTS.
NEXT ONE, BLACK HOLE.
SUZI.
>> UH, WHAT IS THE DISCARDED
PART OF A PUMPERNICKEL BAGEL?
>> HARDWICK: OH, THAT'S GENIUS!
POINTS!
UH, YES, NEXT ONE.
(ZAPPING SOUNDS)
OH, IT'S THE DAILY DOUBLE.
UH, 1969, IF YOU GET... IF YOU
GET POINTS, YOU WILL BE GETTING
DOUBLE POINTS THIS TIME.
SETH MORRIS.
>> WHAT IS A DIFFICULT
FOUR-PERSON SEX POSITION?
>> HARDWICK: YES.
DOUBLE POINTS FOR SETH MORRIS.
WHICH BRINGS YOU ALL THE WAY UP
TO THIRD PLACE.
NEXT ONE, "TO KILL A
MOCKINGBIRD."
YES, OBERG.
>> WHERE ARE YOU GOING WITH ALL
OF THAT MOCKINGBIRD POISON?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
GODDAMN IT.
NEXT ONE... NEXT CLUE, BENEDICT
CUMBERBATCH.
SUZI BARRETT.
>> UH, WHAT IS A SINGLE BAKEABLE
UNIT OF BENEDICT CUMBERS?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.